[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihnen allen auch ohne
hier gleich Unken zu wollen diesem Land
dürfte eine ungemütliche Woche
bevorstehen von sympathischen Protesten
spricht der Bauernverband und von
enormem Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung und
ja tatsächlich die Landwirte sorgen für
unsere Ernährung ohne sie geht es nicht
aber
ob das bei allen noch so in den Sinn
kommt wenn tausende Traktoren
Deutschlands verkehrlen legen das bleibt
abzuwarten der bauernpräsident hatte
einen heißen Januar ausgerufen und
Proteste Zitat wie sie das Land noch
nicht erlebt hat mittlerweile ist die
Bundesregierung den Landwirten
entgegengekommen hat ihre Kürzungspläne
weitgehend wieder einkassiert
mittlerweile hat sich aber auch gezeigt
die Wut bei den Bauern bleibt enorm und
bei manchen von ihnen offenbar auch die
Bereitschaft dabei Grenzen zu
überschreiten Stefan leifert mit
mehr der Weg durch die bayerische
winteridille ist gepflastert mit Wut wer
dieses Jahr zur traditionellen CSU
Klausur will kommt am Protest der
Landwirte nicht vorbei im Kloster Seon
sucht die CSU seit gestern nach einem
Weg sich auf die Seite der Bauern zu
schlagen die Protestform bis hin zur
Bedrohung des Wirtschaftsministers aber
zu verurteilen wir unterstützen diese
Proteste aber sie müssen auf
rechtsstaatlichen Boden stattfinden und
ich hoffe dass solche entleisungen wie
wir es da gesehen haben eine absolute
Ausnahme bleiben da gibt es überhaupt
nichts zu verteidigen seit eine
gewaltbereite Menge Vizekanzler habck am
Donnerstag am Verlassen einer Affäre
hinderte warnt das Bundeskriminalamt
laut Welt am Sonntag vor einer
Unterwanderung durch Rechtsextremisten
Querdenker und andere Gruppierungen mit
umsturzfantasien und andere vielleicht
versuchen sowas auszunutzen und das ist
jetzt das was das eigentliche Problem
ist FT kommt einfach daher dass ein ganz
großer Teil der Bevölkerung überhaupt
keine Hoffnung hat auf normalen Wege
eine Veränderung zu reichen also die
beste Möglichkeit um auf Dauer diesen
afdland den den den Wind zu nehmen oder
radikalen Gruppen die es versuchen zu
missbrauchen ist schlichtteg eine andere
Politik zu machen der Teil der
bauernproteste der aus dem Ruder lief
hat Deutschland eine Debatte um
Protestkultur beschert statt um
Zumutungen für die Landwirtschaft geht
es um die Frage bis wo Protest noch
legitim ist den geht's nicht um die
deutsche Landwirtschaft die haben
umstutzfantasien die Landwirte haben
dankwerterweise große Sympathien in
Deutschland aber das kann man auch
verspielen ab morgen steht Deutschland
eine Woche des Protests bevor während
sich in chatfororen die Aufrufe
hochschaukeln das Land lahm zu legen
Ringen die Parteien um ihre Haltung zum
gewaltsamen Protest in Bayern verläuft
die Linie zwischen Verurteilung und
Unterstützung mittendurch die Koalition
von CSU und Freien Wählern ich sehe das
als politische Notwehr der Bauern was
sie hier machen diese Leute sollen sich
täglich rechtfertigen müssen warum sie
nicht noch mehr arbeiten nicht noch mehr
Steuern zahlen denen wird immer noch
mehr das Wasser abgegraben die CSU
verurteilt die Gewalt unterstützt aber
den Protest auf ihrer Klausur im
bayerischen Seon zeigt auch der
Präsident des ifo Instituts Verständnis
für den Unmut der Bauern über die
Sparpläne der Ampel ich habe mich schon
etwas gewundert dass man einen so großen
Anteil des gesamtsparpakets einer so
kleinen Gruppe zunächst mal zumutet das
ist schon sehr überraschend ist es klar
dass wenn wir die Landwirtschaft als
Teil der Volkswirtschaft insgesamt
betrachten dass die Landwirtschaft hier
einen weit überproportionalen Anteil der
Lasten tragen soll die Welle des
bauernprotests soll morgen von Bayern
aus durch Deutschland rollen auch vor
der Kloster idülle von Seon wird sie
angeblich nicht halt
machen ja Joachim ruckwit steht vor
einer wichtigen Woche er ist Präsident
des Deutschen Bauernverbandes und jetzt
live bei uns Herr ruwit guten
Abend guten Abend Herr sers nachdem
ihnen die Bundesregierung ja jetzt
deutlich entgegengekommen ist und die
Proteste wie wir gesehen haben durchaus
ausarten könnten haben sie mal überlegt
die Protestwoche
abzublasen
nein das haben wir nicht
die Aktionen die Gewalt mit sich bringen
sind ein No Go das haben wir auch in
aller Deutlichkeit gesagt wir haben
unsere Landes und kreisbauenverbände
darauf
hingewiesen dass sie friedlich
demonstrieren sollen alle
Demonstrationen sind angemeldet und wir
sind stark genug auch auf der Grundlage
unserer Verfassung und zu demonstrieren
und unsere an liegen und die haben wir
im Fokus die Rücknahme der
Steuererhöhung in der Rahmen der
Aktionswoche dann zum Ausdruck zu
bringen ihre Anliegen sagen Sie jetzt
hört man aber von verschiedenen
Landwirten auch in Foren im Internet
schon andere Anliegen nämlich z.B den
Aufruf die Ampel zu stürzen äh ist das
in ihrem
Sinn wir sind ein demokratischer Verband
wir stehen zur Verfassung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und wenn es
zu Änderungen in der Regierung kommt
dann über die Stimmabgabe im Wahlbüro in
der Wahlkabine und das ist unser Ansatz
uns geht es jetzt darum diese
einseitigen Belastungen der
Landwirtschaft dass diese zurückgenommen
werden wir sind schon stark belastet die
Direktzahlungen der EU sind in diesem
Jahr um rund 30% gekürzt worden bei den
Haushaltseinsparungen sind wir schon
massiv betroffen mit mehreren 100
Millionen Gemeinschaft sfgabe
Agrarstruktur Küstenschutz wurde gekürzt
der Zuschuss zur landwirtschaftlichen
Unfallversicherung wurde beispielsweise
gekürzt und beim
pauschalierungssatz für die
Landwirtschaft dass die Umsatzsteuer die
die Betriebe erhalten wurde auch gekürzt
das sind schon Kürzungen in der
Größenordnung von rund 2 Milliarden Euro
Herr ruckwi jetzt bekommen allerdings
die Landwirte auch überproportional
viele Vergünstigungen das Vierfache was
ihren Anteil an der Wirtschaftsleistung
eigentlich spräche
ist es da nicht auch nur folgerichtig
dass sie auch stärker ins Visier geraten
wenn es um Kürzungen
geht wenn ich die Summe der öffentlichen
Haushalte betrachte dann fällt der
Agrarbereich mit lediglich gut einem%z
zu Buche also geringer als das was wir
an der Bevölkerung haben insof f die
Hälfte wenn ich kurz unterbrechen da
fast die Hälfte der Gewinne in ihrer
Branche stammt aus Zuschüssen Prämien
Vergünstigungen und auch
Ausgleichszahlungen der öffentlichen
Hand am Ende
das zeigt ja die schwierige
wirtschaftliche Situation in der
Landwirtschaft auf indem wir hohe
Auflagen haben höhere Steuersätze wie in
anderen EU-Mitgliedstaaten ein doppelt
so hohen Mindestlohn wie in Spanien sind
wir auf staatliche Unterstützung
angewiesen und da geht's eben um die
Zukunft unserer Bauernfamilien und da
geht's eben auch um die Frage der
Sicherung der Ernährung der heimischen
Bevölkerung auf der Grundlage heimischer
Erzeugung um das geht es und das ist
meine ich ganz ganz wichtig jetzt gibt
es einige Landwirte denen sind sie vom
Bauernverband wenn ich das so sagen darf
viel zu lasch schon zu sehr
Establishment der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister war vor
zwei Tagen hier im heute journal und er
hat gesagt der Bauernverband muss
aufpassen dass er nicht unterwandert
wird von rechts außen etwa haben sie
auch diese
Sorge nein die haben wir nicht wir sind
politisch unabhängig wir sind stark äh
wir haben starke Persönlichkeiten und
eine ganz ganz starke Mitgliedschaft
unserer Bäuerinnen und Bauern die zu
Europa stehen die zu der Demokratie
stehen die zu unserer Verfassung stehen
da habe ich überhaupt keine Sorge wir
bringen unsere Anliegen mit Nachdruck
zum Ausdruck aber auf Basis der
demokratischen Verfassung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland Herr ruckwit
sie selbst haben aufgerufen zu Protesten
ich zitiere Sie wie Sie das Land noch
nicht erlebt hat zu einem heißen Januar
das kann man jetzt ja vielleicht auch
als Aufforderung lesen jetzt also mal
wirklich loszulegen ist das so ein
bisschen nach dem Motto die Geister die
sie riefen werden sie jetzt nicht mehr
los also die Geister hat die
Bundesregierung gerufen mit ihrem
unsäglichen Vorschlag einer einseitigen
Steuerbelastung der Landwirtschaft das
was wir jetzt in der kommenden Woche
machen das hat der Bauernverband so in
der jüngen Geschichte noch nicht gemacht
nämlich flächendeckend in allen
Bundesländern zu demonstrieren mit
sternfahten und und und wir wissen da
kommt's natürlich zu Einschränkungen zu
Verkehrsbehinderungen und deshalb bitte
ich die Bevölkerung darum dass Sie
Verständnis dafür hat es geht
letztendlich um die Zukunft unserer
Bauernfamilien und um die Zukunft der
heimischen Erzeugung der Bayerische
Bauernverband sagt wir werden
Deutschland notfalls lahm legen er
spricht auch schon von Eingriffen in die
Infrastruktur wenn jetzt Traktoren
Autobahnen und Kreuzungen blockieren
Herr ruckwiet wo ist da noch der
Unterschied zu den
klimaklebern wir haben unsere
Demonstrationen angemeldet die werden
dann auch genehmigt und im Rahmen der
Genehmigungen werden wir dann die
Demonstrationen durchführen wir werden
dafür sorgen dass die rettungskassen
frei sind und werden auch wenn es
notwendig ist äh dann äh die Dinge
schnellstens auf den Weg bringen die
dann auch die Polizei einfordert ganz
kurz noch wann hören die Proteste auf
erst wenn die Bundesregierung komplett
und wirklich zu 100% eingeknickt ist
oder was ist jetzt Ihr konkretes Ziel
wann sie sagen wir haben es
erreicht wir sind schon übergebühr
belastet ich habe das eingangs
aufgezählt das sind schon rund 2
Milliarden Euro mehr verträgt die
Landwirtschaft nicht und deshalb müssen
diese beiden Vorschläge schlichtweg gänz
li vom Tisch sagt Joachim ruckwit der
Präsident des Deutschen Bauernverbandes
Herr ruckwit herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch heute live bei
uns ich bedanke mich ja da gerät einiges
in Bewegung und das weit über
Deutschland hinaus gucken wir auf das
große Bild und es lohnt sich tatsächlich
einen Superlativ rauszuholen noch nie
waren weltweit so viele Menschen zu
einer Wahl aufgerufen wie dieses Jahr
Indien die USA und auch Europa wählt ein
neues Parlament und dabei zeigt sich wie
jetzt bereits in vielen Mitgliedstaaten
der EU ein Ruck nach rechts der sich
abzeichnet
Ulf Röller aus
Brüssel es ist der Abschied von einem
großen Europäer gewesen jack delore war
10 Jahre lang
eu-kmissionspräsident ab
1985 genannt der Architekt eines
gemeinsamen Europas macrons
Abschiedsworte wie eine Warnung nicht in
Nationalismus
zurückzufallen nie wieder dürfe die
Blindheit der Menschen leben niedermähen
und verstümmeln Europas Geschichte leere
Versöhnung als Gast auch Vikor Orban der
Regierungschef Ungarns er verkörpert die
Kraft eines autoritären anderen Europas
seine nationalistische Botschaft halt in
den hauptstdten von Berlin bis nach
Paris
Organisation die unseren Kontinent
zerstört die Rechtspopulisten sind auf
dem Vormarsch feiern Wahlerfolge in
Italien und in Ungarn stellen Sie die
Regierungschefs in der Slowakei und
Finnland sitzen sie in der Regierung in
Schweden unterstützen Sie sie in Holland
haben Sie die Wahl gewonnen und in
Österreich Frankreich und Deutschland
haben sie hohe
umfrageerte und viele andere wollen auch
die Mechanismen die Institution die
Prozesse die Abstimmungen auch das
Abstimmungssystem eigentlich grundlegend
verändern die Europawahl im Juni kann
tektonische politische Verschiebungen
auslösen einen Rechtsruck der
Ex-Präsident und heutige Wahlkämpfer
Trump gilt vielen Rechtspopulisten als
Beispiel für einen politischen
Triumph Clown abgetan und was auch nicht
und das ist natürlich ein immens
inspirierendes Vorbild für andere
Populisten wenn er es geschafft
hat trotz aller seiner ja mutmaßlichen
unwählbarkeit vor 10 Jahren
veröffentlichte Florian hartlepp die
Studie zum Rechtspopulismus mit dem
Titel Europa nein danke seitdem ist die
Strömung in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
vorgedrungen was tun gibt nicht den
Königsweg aber muss auf jeden einwiinden
innertlich thematisch
Koalitionär denn die Ausgrenzung wirkt
offenbar nicht die Probleme dafür sind
zu massiv ein Beispiel dafür Italiens
Regierungschefin Moni die mit einem
antiuropa und einem
antiflüchtlingskurs die Wahlen gewonnen
hatte seitdem hat sie gelernt dass sie
die europäische Solidarität braucht um
Erfolge zu haben Europa
verert Rechtspopulisten und bringt Ihnen
bei dass sie sehr pragmatisch operieren
müssen wenn sie für er Land etwas
gewinnen wollen diese Woche haben sie
einen großen Europäer zu Grabe getragen
sein Erbe fortzusetzen wieder einmal
muss Europa gegen Nationalismus
kämpfen das wird eine spezielle Woche in
Deutschland vor den Protesten der Bauern
hatten wir es ja schon in dieser Sendung
Hanna es gibt noch mehr was den Alltag
stören dürfte ja allerdings bahnreisende
müssen sich ab Mittwoch auf Zugausfälle
einstellen lockführergewerkschaft GDL
hat ab 2 Uhr nachts zum Streik
aufgerufen enden soll dieser am Freitag
um 18 Uhr ein erst am Freitag von der
Deutschen Bahn vorgelegtes neues Angebot
bezeichnete die GDL als substanzlos die
Bahn kündigte an umgehend Rechtsmittel
einzulegen um den Streik zu
stoppen in der Debatte um das Bürgergeld
hat Arbeitsminister Heil seine Pläne für
eine Verschärfung der Sanktionen für
jobverweigerer noch einmal bei Berlin
direkt bekräftigt es gehe darum ein
deutliches Zeichen zu setzen denn das
Bürgergeld sei kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen wir reden über die
Menschen die kleine Gruppe von Menschen
die total Verweigerer sind und ich finde
dass diese Minderheit von Menschen
wieder das System in Verruf beraten
lassen darf noch die Menschen übrigens
die Bürgergeld sich redlich anstrengen
und bemühen aus ihrer not rauszukommen
es geht um Gerechtigkeit um Solidarität
aber eben auch um
eigenverantwort die CSU Landesgruppe hat
am zweiten Tag ihrer winterklausur in
Kloster Seon härtere Strafen für
Antisemitismus gefordert so will sie
diesen als besonders schweren Fall der
Volksverhetzung einstufen mit einer
Freiheitsstrafe von mindestens 6 Monaten
der Präsident des Zentralrats der Juden
Schuster der für Gespräche zu Gast war
äußerte sich zustimmend und erklärte
Bildung sei wichtig Abs ckung aber
auch nach einem Polizeieinsatz in einer
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung in Mülheim an
der Ruhe ist ein geflüchteter gestorben
die Polizei war gerufen worden weil der
26-Jährige Mann aus Guinea gestern Abend
randaliert und Mitarbeiter angegriffen
habe teilte die Polizei Essen mit laut
den Beamten leistete er während des
Einsatzes massiven Widerstand die
Polizisten setzten Elektroschocker ein
nach seiner Festnahme verstarb der Mann
im Krankenhaus noch in der Nacht übernah
die Polizei Bochum die
Ermittlungen nach dem Zwischenfall mit
einer Boeing 737 MAX 9 hat die
europäische Agentur für Flugsicherheit
ein vorübergehendes Startverbot für
Maschinen dieses Typs angeordnet und
folgt damit der US Aufsichtsbehörde
Fluggesellschaften sind nun aufgefordert
die Maschinen zu überprüfen bevor diese
wieder abheben dürfen am Freitag war bei
einem Flug von Alaska Airlines ein Teil
der Kabinenwand samt Fenster abgerissen
die Maschine musste notlanden schwer
verletzt wurde niemand außministerin
berärburg hat sich auf ihrer Nahostreise
offen für die Lieferung von Kampfjets
des Typs Eurofighter an Saudi-Arabien
gezeigt so könne Saudi-Arabien Drohnen
und Raketen abfangen die von den hui
Milizen im Yemen auf Israel abgefeuert
werden erklärte bbock Deutschland werde
sich britischen Überlegungen zu weiteren
eurofighern für Saudi-Arabien nicht
entgegenstellen die Ministerin hatte
sich in Jerusalem zuvor mit dem
israelischen Präsidenten Herzog und
ihrem Amtskollegen Katz getroffen
berbock sprach sich dabei auch für einen
besseren Schutz von Zivilisten im
Gazastreifen
aus exakt drei Monate ist es her seit
der terrorüberfall der Hamas auf Israel
alles veränderte in Nahost und
unfassbares Leid über unbeteiligte
Menschen brachte auf allen Seiten denn
mittlerweile tobt ein gazarieg der alles
in den Schatten stellt was es an
Zerstörungen in der Vergangenheit dort
gab und Gaza hat viel Zerstörung erlebt
zwei weitere Journalisten sind heute in
Gaza getötet worden der Sender aljasera
wirft Israel vor die Grundsätze der
Pressefreiheit zu verletzen das
Kriegsgebiet ist bereits seit längerem
auch für Reporter eine
Todeszone ausländische Journalisten
werden nach wie vor nicht nach Gaza
gelassen zur Berichterstattung Ausnahme
gemeinsam mit der Israel Armee unser
Korrespondent michael bwerunge war auf
diese Weise heute im Tunnelsystem der
Hamas hier ist seine
Reportage die Sperrmauer zwischen Israel
und Gaza an der Grenzstation eres die
grifft die Hamas vor genau drei Monaten
als erstes an Kameras und automatische
Waffen wurden zerstört Israels
hightecharmee im Sturm überrandt wir
wurden definitiv am 7 Oktober überrascht
aber man sieht auch mit welcher Wut sie
rüber kam mit tausenden Terroristen das
hat hatten wir so nicht auf dem Radar
wie sehr die Armee überrascht wurde
führt sie uns Journalisten im
Niemandsland gleich hinter der Mauer
selbst vor dort wurde ein Tunneleingang
in unmittelbarer Nähe zur Grenze
entdeckt kaum zu glauben dass es die
hamaske schaffter diesen Tunnel
unbemerkt bis nur wenige Meter an die
israelischen Grenzanlagen
heranzutreiben Abstieg in die Unterwelt
der Hammers die mit größter Präzision
angelegt und ausgebaut wurde die dies
ist einer ihrer größten Tunnel 4 km lang
und bis zu 50 m tief möglicherweise
wurde er für den Angriff am 7 Oktober
errichtet dann aber doch nicht
genutzt na ja das ist natürlich ein
angriffstunnel weil er wirklich nur 400
m ungefähr von der Grenze zu Israel
aufhört und es hat natürlich nur einen
Sinn dass sie wenn sie angreifen wollen
eventuell diesen Tunnel nutzen obwohl
sie ih am 7 Oktober nicht genutzt haben
wie die Hamas dabei vorging hat sie
selbst in einem Video dokumentiert zum
Teil bohrten die Arbeiter von Hand zum
Teil mit einer Art selbstgebastelter
Tunnelbohrmaschine auch an der
Stromversorgung fehlte es nicht der
Bruder von hamasführer sinua soll gar in
einem Kleinwagen im Tunnel gesichtet
worden sein in der Kriegsführung der
Hamas spielt das Tunnelsystem insgesamt
eine zentrale Rolle es kann sein dass
sie von dort ihre Operation ausführen es
kann sein dass sie dort Geiseln gefangen
halten das sind Unterschlupf Orte
natürlich das sind Orte wo sie raket von
A nach B schieben wenn Sie wollen und
die Terroristen selbst wenn Sie von A
nach B wollen Millionen von Geldern und
Kubikmetern Beton die nicht dem zivilen
Aufbau von Gaza zugute kamen sondern der
Kriegsführung der Hammers sehr viel von
diesem Zement was auch über israelischen
Grenzübergang Kerem schalom nach Gaza
reingekommen ist oder über Ägypten wurde
natürlich nicht oberirdisch sondern
unterirdisch benutzt für die Terroristen
und nicht für die Bevölkerung im
Gazastreifen sowie vieles andere für
Israel wird der Kampf gegen eine Arm im
Untergrund noch auf absehbare Zeit ein
Problem bleiben viele Tunnel und
tunnelausgänge sind noch gar nicht
entdeckt und die Armee geht davon aus
dass sie gar nicht alle finden wird und
auch gar nicht alle zerstören kann die
Tunnel von Gaza wahrscheinlich die
stärkste Waffe der Hamas in diesem
Krieg so jetzt machen wir in der Sendung
einen Schnitt und einen Sprung und
gucken auf den Sport sononntag han was
war losja da lief es für die deutschen
Frauen beim Biathlon Heimweltcup in
Oberhof nicht so gut mit schwachen
Schießleistungen reicht es nur für Platz
5 wesentlich erfolgreicher waren die
Männer sie mussten sich nur den starken
Norwegern geschlagen geben und landeten
angefeuert von mehr als 20.000
Zuschauern auf Platz
2 bei der prestigetächtigen tourdi ist
mit Friedrich moch nach 15 Jahren wieder
ein deutscher Langläufer auf das Podest
gestürmt auf der letzten teils sehr
steilen Etappe wurde der 23-Jährige
allguer zweiter und schob sich damit
auch im Gesamtklassement auf Platz 2 vor
die heutige Etappe gewann der Franzose
Jul lapier der Gesamtsieg der tourdei
ging an Harald Östberg amunsen aus
Norwegen das deutsche Tennisteam hat im
australischen Sydney das Finale im
United Cup gegen Polen gewonnen zunächst
hatte im Einzel Angeli Kerber verloren
danach siegte Alexander ZF die
Entscheidung im gemein gemischten
Mannschaftswettbewerb fiel im Doppel
Laura Siegemund und Alexander zwerev
besiegten das polnische topduo knapp mit
6:4 5:7 und 10:4 im Match
tibreak er war kein Politiker er hat
nichts erfunden hat keine lebensrettende
Medizin entwickelt er hat nichts anderes
getan als Bücher und Artikel zu
schreiben das sagt ein
philosophieexperte über Immanuel Kant
und trotzdem prägt seine auf das reine
Denken bezogene Existenz unsere Welt bis
heute was kN postulierte ist heute noch
überall präsent es ist relevant in der
politischen Auseinandersetzung auch mit
unserer Zeit das Konzept des mündigen
Bürgers die Menschenwürde im Grundgesetz
kannt gibt halt wie gut dass dieses Jahr
kantjahr ist der 300 geburtstag des
modernen Denkers Normen
odental man muss bei Kant nicht in der
Küche anfangen kann man aber denn Klopse
das ist kantche küchenphilosophie der
Denker konnte sich auf dem Tisch nichts
Besseres denken als den Schmaus seiner
Heimat Königsberger Klopse voller Bauch
studiert nicht gern galt nicht für kannt
den erkenntnishungrigen den
dauerdenker Klöpse liegen schon schwer
im Magen ja wenn ich schwere Kost esse
dann dann eher wenn ich danach nichts
mehr vorhabe schwere Kost im Restaurant
der Bonner Bundeskunsthalle und eine
Etage höher auch eben wegen jenem Kant
um den sich hier alles dreht des
philosophenafel ist reich gedeckt was er
uns hinterlassen
hat ich glaube das wichtigste ist
tatsächlich sich seines eigenen
Verstandes zu bedienen dazu den Mut zu
haben in jeder Hinsicht sowohl gegenüber
sich selbst kritisch zu sein wie auch
gegenüber anderen sich zu klar zu machen
dass wir verantwortlich sind und nicht
wir die Verantwortung an irgendwelcher
anderen abgeben können auch nicht an die
da oben ganz berühmte Frage lautet ja
was soll ich tun und nicht worüber kann
ich klagen aber in der gefühlten
Umzingelung von Krisen fällt das Klagen
heute leicht das kritisieren das
Ignorieren Querdenken das besser wissen
das hat natürlich eine gewisse Ironie
also kN fordert zum Selbstdenken auf und
dann berufen sich Leute die vielleicht
nicht sehr gründlich Selbstdenken gerade
auf Kant es ist ja nicht so als sei m
dogmatische Meinung ich habe immer recht
dasselbe wie Selbstdenken oder kritische
kritisches Denken im Sinne Kanz vor 300
Jahren erblickte kannt das Licht der
Welt in Königsberg dass er Zeit seines
Lebens nicht verließ trotzdem gilt seine
Weisheit heute weltweit seine Maßstäbe
an Moral hielten Einzug ins Grundgesetz
und bei den Vereinten Nationen sind dort
sicher nicht nur Kleingedrucktes
Menschenwürde Rechtstaat Freiheit
Demokratie dazu das Ziel ewiger Friede
sofern wir davon sind würde Kant an uns
verzweifeln nein das glaube ich nicht
also Kant würde sicherlich ohnehin nicht
verzweifeln weil Verzweiflung eine
Einstellung ist die am Ende ja
kontraproduktiv ist und die nach KZ
eigener Auffassung moralisch falsch ist
wir dürfen nicht verzweifeln wir müssen
den Mut behalten wir müssen Hoffnung
bewahren und auf die richtigen
politischen und moralischen Ziele
hinarbeiten ausgerechnet Putin der
Aggressor der Kriegsfürst so heißt es
Schätze Kant aber würde Kant auch Putin
schätzen nein das kann ich mir überhaupt
gar nicht vorstellen kant war ja ein
Verfechter des freiheitlichen
Rechtsstaates der Demokratie
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen das
Kant den heutigen Zustand des russischen
Staates befürworten würde Immanuel Kant
Denker Genie Mensch der sich sexistisch
äußerte rassistisch judenfeindlich der
danach verlangt dass man sich auch mit
ihm kritisch auseinandersetzt ihn zu
überdenken es wäre ganz im Sinne
Kanz da haben wir es gerade gesehen vor
300 Jahren ist er geboren 1804 starb er
mit eben diesen letzten Worten es ist
gut so und jetzt ganz unphilosophisch
zurück zum nüchternen
Nachrichtengeschäft was bringt uns die
kommende Woche außer massiven
bauernprotesten und lockführerstreiks
darüber haben wir ja bereits ausführlich
geredet heute weitere wichtige Termine
jetzt dem heute journal Ausblick von
Franziska
feske
am Montag wird die ehemalige
linkenpitikerin Sarah Wagenknecht
offiziell ihre neue Partei vorstellen in
der Vergangenheit hatte sie für ein Ende
der Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
geworben und für eine strengere
Migrationspolitik nach monatelangem
Streit war Wagenknecht Ende Oktober aus
der linken ausgetreten gemeinsam mit
neun weiteren
Bundestagsabgeordneten am Mittwoch wird
die handballuropameisterschaft starten
zum ersten Mal in Deutschland in der
Vorrunde wartet auf die DHB Auswahl mit
Frankreich direkt einer der Topfavoriten
los geht's in der kommenden Woche aber
erstmal im eigigen dafür umgebauten
Düsseldorfer Fußballstadion gegen die
Schweiz live zu sehen im
ZDF am Samstag werden in Taiwan
Präsident und Parlament neu gewählt
dabei wird auch über das zukünftige
Verhältnis zu China entschieden die
Volksrepublik betrachtet Spitzenkandidat
William von der aktuell Regierenden
Fortschrittspartei als Separatisten
Peking kündigt immer wieder eine
Wiedervereinigung beider Staaten an
notfalls auch mit militärischen
Mitteln und jetzt der Blick auf die
sonnigkeitten
Wetteraussichten morgen setzt sich im
Nordosten die Sonne durch auch sonst ist
es freundlich nur an den Alpen Schneid
es noch leicht bei kaltem Nordostwind
werden Temperaturen von -7 bis + 1°
reicht der Dienstag wird meist sonnig ab
Mittwoch liegen Nebel und
Hochnebelfelder über dem Norden sonst
bleibt es bei viel Sonne trotz sehr
kalten Nächten wird es tagsüber wieder
etwas
milder ja viel Sonne das nehmen wir
gerne mit der Dienstplan sagt ab morgen
übernehmen hier Marietta Slomka und
Heinz Wolf von uns allen in der
sonntagscrew danke für Ihr Interesse und
die nächsten Nachrichten gibt's hier
gegen 0:25 Uhr einen angenehmen Abend
wünschen wir
tschüss
[Musik]
ه